bro I don't never forget anything what
did I say you want me to tell people
what happened in that room oh he's going
to tell everyone now he doesn't forget
anything he's going to tell everybody
now oh trust me somebody going to get H
it real bad let's see who it is right
now say it it was me luk Balmar his
brother do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad
has helped develop allot of us it's
extremely beneficial to do this course
definitely recommend this
course to access the free life-changing
training
now asalam Alum brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well in
I'm here with Zan how you doing Zan you
right alhamdulillah that's good I am
good how are you nice nice very nice
people can't see the shal me but I can
yeah it's because it's the to upper part
of the body in it yeah nice we talk
about somebody okay Al sisters we are
going to be reacting to a video which I
found so interesting yeah when I saw uh
fresh I don't know what his name is but
they call him fresh I think it's fresh
Yeah so basically he's uh when remember
hijab was giving him da and he just
could not get it through like his logic
or rationale that one plus you know the
Trinity yeah and he was keep arguing as
2 plus two is four he's like no it might
not be and I was thinking like and I I
mean you can't really blame him in the
sense well you can in the sense if you
believe in the Trinity you know 1+ 1+
one is one I mean 2 plus two is not
going to be four it's going to be five
but you thought it's just maybe a oneof
thing it's a belief thing whatever it is
ETC no problem logic and rational goes
out the window here Sino is having a
debate with him yeah and it's so
interesting bro just let's watch it for
ourself in and he's making some rational
logical points but for some odd reason
why shirtless pictures of you oh that's
because I'm training so basically I need
to send it to my coach to see how my
body fat is uh oh this story is long bro
does it have an intermission no no it
doesn't haven't provided any substantial
evidence for why I made a mistake like
I'm in a good position financially I
still have access to my platform able to
do what I love doing I I'm very blessed
um my family like where where have I
made a mistake where like if I made a
mistake there' be something wrong in my
life or something missing or something
that I wish that I had and there's
nothing there's zero regret for anything
I've done that's good so is it really a
mistake then bro no because where he is
now but back then I was less successful
when I was still on YouTube I
know okay I'm I'm let's just he's doing
better now without YouTube I know so
how's that mistake
well dude what are you talking
about I'm going to leave it there I'm
leave it there bro I don't think you
made a mistake man I think like I said
that was funny yeah that was towards the
end that's funny yeah but this is how it
kind of started okay let's go one people
are not going to be consecrators how do
you know okay the bigger point is that
no matter what happens tell the truth do
not let these people hold your balls and
let you and decide what you believe is
true and what's not as true who these
people the okay fresh we know the people
that run the platform forms see this is
why I different from your opinion and
your your thoughts because I think
everyone should make a choice it doesn't
have to be always go on this path and be
a Marty I think you can you don't have
to be a Marty no no but you're saying
I'm I'm not saying you have to do at all
costs and Ru ruin things for your some
people need to do that yeah but not
everyone okay so you I'm ARG people that
don't want to do this [__] is that okay
then then if you guys don't want to tell
the truth that's okay I'm saying you're
you're shaming it I'm tell the truth
you're that's fine yeah but your your
rhetoric is that you're shaming it away
like you should have done this you could
have made more money you could have you
could have had Twitter you could have
had Snapchat you could have had YouTube
whatever you lose it and then you still
do it anyway you still succeed
regardless and that's good for you so
then why do you keep bringing it up as
if it's something that like I made a
mistake okay that's the second one yeah
okay that's very interesting Mak some
very valid points that you speak the
truth I mean um this I think sneo had
this principle before he became a Muslim
and like said some of the disbelievers
if they became to Islam they would have
they would exceed they would become so
much better and you can see those
principles carried onto Islam it only
made him shine more so we're going to
come to a few points very important
about about speaking the truth and we're
going to go to B is which is very
interesting uh how when Allah ordered
them something and talking about
truthful being truthful uh I think he
kept straw maning him as well like sn's
main point was that why are you shaming
me yes and then he's like yeah but
everyone doesn't have to do it yeah yeah
but can can I be on that side yeah but
that's not the point that you're arguing
yeah he's saying basically everyone
don't have to do it and I don't want you
to do it who are you like he's okay with
it here is where he's the truth now here
he's basically now trying to expose him
like oh I know something remember we
spoke about this let's let's see what he
has to bring cuz it might be something
like okay you know what this is behind
the SC like this happened in the UK he
even goes to the C should I should I say
it now and he go like yeah let's see
what it is cuz I'm I'm really intrigued
I mean you guys must be as well okay so
you could decide do you want to make
more money and then not tell the truth
and not have convictions or do you want
to tell the truth regardless and make a
difference in the world if you want to
make more money and run around with
celebrities and sell your soul that's
fine it's really a choice if do you want
to sell your soul or not I would rather
tell the truth I don't my soul is not
for sale if you want to sell it okay but
that's not you should not say mistake to
have
conviction see you you change your
opinion nowadays when I've never changed
my opinion about this I asked you this
when we're in the UK and someone warned
you and we spoke on the phone about it
you were there too as well two years ago
the day I got banned yes yes yeah it was
difficult but that's what I'm saying I
did I never regretted anything that I've
done telling the truth I've never told
you that I've never said that I don't
know why you believe that bro I don't I
never forget anything what did I say you
want me to tell people what happened in
that room oh he's going to tell everyone
now he doesn't forget anything he's
going to tell everybody now oh trust me
somebody going to get H real bad let's
see it is now say it it was me L balar
his brother get real serious it's about
to get real serious now it's going to be
mad I don't think I can bear this I
think we're going to change opinion on
sne we need to is he strap in has he
been has he been lying to us that he's a
Muslim does the sofa have seat belts no
sneo you're about to get exposed uh mine
wasn't there and remember is mental
olation holding you back in
business so many entrepreneurs have big
that was before I got banned I know I
know I'm the full Contex right and they
warned me you're going to for five
minutes yes you warned me What's happen
and I did not care understandable then
we were shopping me you and Musa in your
UK you got an email or a text something
like that you got banned you were
instantly like [__] like anybody would
be you were like damn like quiet as a
mouse understandable I I'll be same way
too then I was like [__] bro what are
you going to do now remember told you
you're like I don't know understandable
then I asked you a little later on do
you do you regret doing this you said no
but you did say we should didn't happen
because things will be different you
probably further ahead okay so you just
provve my point huh you just proved my
point I never reg the decision no no
okay so this this is where it just like
I was like okay you just proved his
point which he was like he's basically
saying because you was upset because it
was hard because it was like how do I go
in from here that means you regret it
he's said no bro being a Mart for a
cause it's not easy it's not flipping
easy it's not something you go and it's
like oh it's hard somebody might be
crying in pain screaming whatever that
doesn't mean they're not acknowledge
their marm or happy that they follow
that Pursuit they're in pain it's normal
human reactions have it's like the
prophet when he lost his son and he was
crying and they said oh M why are you
crying you're the prophet he said am I
not a human being yeah can I not show
emotions he's basically saying oh no you
know you showed emotions when that
happened you was of course you are any
of us would be bro if our platforms were
shut I would you think I'm going to be
like yeah but I'm so happy no of course
it's something that you've built you've
worked hard on Etc whatever for that
matter but it's not the end of the world
but still you're going to be there's a
there's a difference between your
emotional reaction to something and your
moral stance with regards to something
exactly and you know what's very
interesting you look at in the Quran
when Allah talks to B is and tells them
not to fish in the Sabbath something
very interesting happens the scholars
say that there were because Allah says
in the Quran we are the greatest um why
because we enjoying good and forbid evil
yeah this is something the previous
Nations the Christians and the Jews
stopped doing in joining evil when we
see evil we try to stop it so when they
were told to not fish in the Sabbath the
scholars divide three types of groups
number one the ones who broke the
Covenant and went and fished in the
Sabbath not literally but they put the
Nets out to trick God yeah those were
the ones that were destroyed number two
there were the group who said no we're
going to obey Allah's Commandments and
not to fish on the Sabbath there's a
third group the third group was the ones
the scholars say that watched it happen
and didn't do anything they were just
like listen you want to do it that's you
the scholar say Allah destroyed the ones
who fished in the Sabbath put the N Out
and the ones who did not speak out
against it why because this makes you
complicit in the evil do you get it it's
because when you see it's like what they
call the silent devil or um what's the
word there's a word for I can't remember
but the thing is what when you see evil
bro and if you are not seeing anything
against it like the prophet said if you
see evil try to stop with your hand if
not speak out against it at least the
low lowest form is hate it in your heart
so to me sneo is enacting that by saying
listen bro I'm not selling myself out
and d and he's and he's fresh this guy
fresh he making no logical point he's
saying I don't have regrets I'm happy
where I am I've got more opportunities
which comes to yes and we spoke to about
this yeah Allah will replace Allah says
inah if you fear me I will give you a
way out from places you can never
imagine so he's sticking to principle
but it's as if fresh is telling him no
but you should have still not do that
that's it's interesting you mentioned
principle because they say that somebody
who doesn't stand for something will
fall for anything yeah and this is what
we're seeing a lot of today like and
this is what the prophet described the
as well that you will become like the
froth on the sea and the froth if you
look it's of no value it's of no
consideration you don't take it
seriously the actual thing is the body
of water the froth is pretty much
useless and if you look the um is pretty
much 1.8 billion yeah we have a genocide
taking place not a single leader has
sent an army there not a single leader
has got involved protecting them um
militarily and you know what it's it's
such an embarrassment and it's funny
because even if you look from a
strategic point of view um when you talk
about controversial issues you actually
drive more engagement and more clicks
and that's I think because sneo is not
only doing that he's also targeting a
niche as well something that not many
people are targeting that makes him kind
of stand out now fresh and fit also did
the same thing with regards to red pill
and masculinity in fact just recently so
ironic they actually got removed from
twitch Midstream BR they got demonetized
on YouTube yeah so so fresh why why why
you don't why are you doing this if you
didn't do this opportunities would be
more on Twitch I mean there's
sponsorship ex you lost it why don't you
go along with liberalism and feminism
and contribute to the destruction of
society no because you believe that
there is actually um that that's that's
dangerous and you want to curb that and
you want to work on the other side but
then isn't isn't sneo doing exactly the
same thing in a different sphere yeah
exactly then I I don't understand it's
it's like the kettle calling the yeah
the cut black yeah I think i' I've
screwed that up nice I don't know what
he said but he sounded amazing yeah the
kettle called the nice wait hey
Siri mhm what is the quote Kettle called
the cup
black okay I found this on the web for
what is theote called the black check it
out the pot calling the kettle black
yeah the pot calling the kettle black
it's interesting your my sir
answered yeah it's like and mine's still
asleep yeah it's like uh the pot calling
the kettle black I like that that was
one time take that was brilliant it's
not good to
lie but yeah look you and the thing is
like you said before BR they have this
they're you know what it is it can be
because it can't be that they they're
doing the same thing with feminism yeah
so it shows that maybe he's trying to
say oh it's not worth it for Islam or
it's not worth it for um talking about
this or that so it maybe Val things it's
like something that he values CU to him
it's like yeah because they're doing the
same they're getting canceled so I'll be
honest he made no sense at all I was
really waiting for him to drop a bomb
shell like yeah he's going to bro what
did you bring you just reaffirmed what
sneo said did you get it so to me I mean
alhamdulillah Allah says in the Quran
speak the truth even if it's against
yourself or your kin this is the
principles a Muslim lives by and sneo
had these principles before Islam and he
only beautified him when he came to
Islam by speaking out against truth and
let me tell you something and that is
what before Islam yeah he did BR he was
someone always spoke about like you know
it it was very bold you know when it
comes to yeah he's always like that so
to me like to talk about red peel Etc I
mean if you truly are a person who are
going to talk about manhood the first
principle you should have is speaking
the truth on that note brother and
sisters in I hope you guys enjoyed the
video and yeah till next
time is that Muhammad hijab think so
nice don't forget brother and sisters
Muhammad hijab debate is coming up on
Thursday inshah go open the door for him
byebye